[Music]
you're in incredible shape and one of
the things that I've actually heard you
talk about and you've written about is
you work a lot on your abs and people
talk about the core and the abs but I
mean how serious are you about this how
hard are you working on the abs well I
don't do sit-ups generally I mean once
in a blue moon I will if I'm like in the
mood but I hate them for the most part
like everybody else and so my dad in the
village back in the day he used to have
people throw rocks on his stomach and
they would get bigger and bigger he
would bounce them off at popeye by any
chance sexy I tell ya he would have
people throw rocks at his abdomen yes
and he would bounce them off and he
would tell me these stories and I always
wanted to be like my dad so I was like I
don't want people throwing rocks at me
how about I just have people punch me so
all the time since I can't even remember
I've always had people punch me in the
stomach and then I have to constrict my
abs and by the time they get the courage
like if I ask you to punch me right now
you're gonna be like no no no meanwhile
I'm already tight and ready ready ready
ready for the punch and by the time you
do it I've done like the equivalent of
50 sit-ups right right so it's the
preparation for the punch yeah paranoia
workout yeah it's gonna hit me I don't
want to hit you know I mean okay I'd
like okay well
busted ribs so be gentle
on this side wait wait you can't because
these ribs are broken I don't want to do
this I don't win in any way tomorrow
people aren't gonna be like you really
did a good job
punching Maria Menounos over here just
like right there ah that's great that's
like a tan right there come on come on
come on
[Applause]
Boonen you just got hotter those abs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you had been an incredible trance and
then you broke me out of it
I was feeling something from Maria and
then she laughed I love your laugh